[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe sur les
marchés pour mieux comprendre on reçoit
ce soir Jean-Paul Giacometti
gestionnaire de portefeuille chez Claret
bonsoir bonsoir c'est un plaisir de vous
retrouver donc aujourd'hui si on prend
la journée d'aujourd'hui excellente
journée pour les indices boursiers
surtout ceux qui sont influencés par le
secteur des techno qu'est-ce qui se
passe pour le Nasdaq entre autres parce
que ça craintes oui ça grimpe bien ça
grimpe fort mais ça dépend de où vous
mesurez c'est sûr que si vous prenez
juste un exemple simple que vous
commencez à 100 dollars descendez à 20
et remonter à 30 le 20 à 30 c'est 50% de
hausse et c'est ce qu'on vit en ce
moment
c'est une sorte de rebond et combiné
avec des attentes si on peut dire ce que
pas tout à fait français mais des
attentes positives quant à l'inflation
et auto-intéresse ce que je doute un peu
est-ce que c'est un on a l'impression
que c'est un rebond rapide ou du moins
une remontée qui s'effectue en quelques
jours quelques semaines on avait des
progressions de presque 11% pour le le
mois de janvier seulement hier à peu
près 2% aujourd'hui 3%, est-ce qu'on est
sur une lancée peut-être en fait ça peut
durer plus longtemps qu'on pense le
négativisme était tellement élevé la
chute était tellement forte mais faut
regarder au niveau où on est c'est quand
même pas des aubaines du siècle mais la
même Tom est installée les gens pensent
que la hausse des taux est presque finie
et ce facteur là influence beaucoup les
titres de technologie parlant de titre
spécifique on faisait une petite liste
là-dessus qui ont publié le résultat
financier aujourd'hui Apple Amazon
alphabet entre autres
qui qui semble être moins bien reçu
après la fermeture des marchés
aujourd'hui des reculs pour ces titres
là qu'est-ce qui fait réagir les
investisseurs là dans les messages qui
ont été envoyés aujourd'hui par les
grandes sociétés de la Silicon Valley
faut pas oublier que ces compagnies là
5-10 ans étaient beaucoup plus petite
donc un taux de croissance quand vous
êtes plus petit de 20% et beaucoup plus
facile qu'un taux de croissance de 20%
quand vous êtes un
donc les attentes vont d'après moi
diminuer avec le temps tout simplement
parce que c'est compagnies n'arrêtent
pas de grandir et si on pose ça à la
limite il va en rester juste une qui va
tout contrôler à la fin ce qui devrait
pas arriver du moins on laisse faire
donc c'est un peu ça c'est que les
attentes sont de la un peu élevées ce
qui resteralise c'est un peu plus bas
mais c'est compagnies font encore
beaucoup d'argent oui absolument parce
que la croissance 100% Tage est
peut-être plus fait mais lorsqu'on
regarde honnête le montant en milliard
si vous voulez qui se génère en profit
vous êtes pointé
100% Tage de qu'est-ce que vous
grossissez et ces compagnies-là
tranquillement avec le temps d'après moi
avant tout simplement avoir un ratio
moins élevé que ce que c'était par le
passé pour l'instant les nouvelles sont
bonnes les taux d'intérêt tout le monde
pense qu'ils monteront plus ou en tout
cas du moins ce qui est favorable pour
eux je vous amène sur mes tas avant de
passer à l'analyse un peu plus macro si
vous voulez mettant aujourd'hui
de ses meilleures journées en disant on
disait 23% de progression par contre les
résultats sont mitigés on dit
en fait on a supprimé des emplois on se
met l'emploi récemment ils sont pas
beaucoup y avoir d'appétit pour le
fameux métaver de Mark Zuckerberg alors
pourquoi cette enthousiasme par rapport
à l'État mais je pense que Monsieur
une très belle présentation en mettant
de côté le nouvel met à verse futur
monde virtuel pour se changer ces mots
pour en anglais jeans l'intelligence
artificielle et en mentionnant que ça va
très bien on fait des profits donc la
compagnie continue à faire beaucoup
d'argent mais il y a mis beaucoup moins
d'enfance et prononcer le mot
métaverse presque pas dans son discours
donc les gens l'ont perçu comme a
peut-être qu'ils veulent laisser de côté
pour aller vers d'autres choses et c'est
quand même une compagnie que bien
réussie dans plusieurs domaines à
travers le temps et c'est la moins chère
ou dans les moins chère seul l'été avant
en tout cas peut-être un des éléments
qui explique cette remontée donc on a
parlé du Nasdaq brièvement j'aimerais
vous montrer le graphique qui nous
montre assez bien ce qui s'est produit
je vais vous ramener début 2020 vous
voyez lorsqu'on a commencé l'ascension
là après la pandémie jusqu'au sommet en
le c'était le 19 novembre en 2021 et par
la suite l'espèce de baisse en denti qui
a été notre cauchemar en 2022 est-ce
qu'on va retrouver ce sommet là on
disait janvier en ce moment ça se passe
relativement bien qu'est-ce qui nous
attend pour le Nasdaq monsieur Jacobins
dites-moi ce qui va arriver au taux
d'intérêt puis je vais vous le dire bon
donc aux États-Unis on nous dit d'autres
hausses mais enfin en vue on va le voir
avec le temps l'inflation c'est je pense
que vous en parlez plus tard dans
l'émission l'inflation c'est un animal
qui est difficile à contrôler donc si
vous laissez aller courir trop vite
l'arrêter par la suite c'est encore plus
difficile c'est ce qu'on a vécu dans les
années 70 moi tout ce que j'espace et
qui monte encore les taux pour justement
pas que ça parte en cavale
et si c'est le cas ben c'est
compagnies-là que plus le taux d'intérêt
élevé parce que compagnies font beaucoup
de profits dans le futur un taux
d'intérêt de vie veut dire qu'un dollar
fait dans 10 ans ça vaut pas la même
chose avec un taux d'intérêt de zéro
vous pouvez payer très cher c'est
compagnies avec des taux d'intérêt plus
élevé vous payez un peu moins cher donc
c'est compagnie vont continuer à faire
de l'argent c'est juste qu'on va payer
moins pour très bien en terminant là on
a vécu beaucoup d'anxiété par rapport à
nos placements ça va prendre combien de
temps avant qu'on récupère les pertes de
2022 ça dépend si une récession cette
année dans l'histoire c'est une baisse
importante et suivie d'une récession la
ça dure deux ans donc il nous en
resterait pour 6 à 8 mois 9 mois s'il y
a pas de récession dans l'histoire on a
passé le pire donc peu importe ce que
c'est vraiment important moi je parierai
pas sur me mettre sur les lignes de côté
pendant 9 mois parce que si vous vous
trompez vous allez être lente c'est
l'horizon c'est 5 à 10 ans que vous
devez regarder en avant pas 5 à 3 jours
ou 5 à 10 mois c'est toujours pour ça
qu'on vous invite monsieur Giacometti un
bon rappel et de bons conseils non merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]